We've
done in our politics is create
a situation where we're electing idiots
and
and so
I don't look at it
through the lens of like, you know,
is this what I should do or what
I shouldn't do?
I look at it through the lens of
how do we elect serious people?
And I think electing serious people
can't be partizan.
We're back now with GOP
presidential candidate Asa Hutchinson.
Some laughs there in the room for that,
but she's making a serious point.
Do you think it's a fair one?
Well, of course I disagree
about the characterization.
I've been elected
governor twice in Arkansas,
and I look at my colleagues
across the country.
They really have a public mindedness.
They're very bright and credible.
Something tells me she
wasn't talking about same way
Well, I know that,
but I'm making the point.
There's really good people that serve.
And even if you look at the ones
running for president,
there's 12 Republicans running.
Most of them are serious.
Candidates that bring great credentials.
I think our point, obviously,
is that we need candidates
and we need elected leaders
that have courage.
They stand for convictions
that speak the truth
and do not always listen
to the loudest voice in the room.
That's what I believe
the American people want and need.
And also it reminds me that our founding
fathers understood
that we're all humans and we're flawed.
And so that's why
there's a system of checks and balances.
And that's why
we have the different
branches of government.
The United States Supreme Court today
really affirmed the check and balance of
of a judicial judicial
where they can overrule legislative
laws that are unconstitutional.
That's a foundational in our country.
Those checks and balances are important
but in this election,
we do need serious candidates,
people of courage and integrity.
And that's why
I think Iowa
and New Hampshire
is going to do a good job
of sorting through that.
All right.
We'll see
how this unfolds for you as well.
Governor Asa Hutchinson, thank
you very much.